&gt;&gt; Well for one possibility 2 d plus one can be at negative 7, or equal to
negative 7, and for the other case 2 d plus one can equal positive 7. &gt;&gt; You
might have thought about this in your head, or maybe you did some equation
solving. &gt;&gt; We can subtract 1 from both sides to get 2 d is equal to negative 8
then divide both sides by 2, &gt;&gt; So d would equal negative 4. &gt;&gt; For this
equation, we subtract 1 from both side to get 2d equals 6, then we divide both
sides by 2, so d would equal 3. &gt;&gt; If I think about plugging 3 in for d, I get 6
plus 1 which is 7. &gt;&gt; And if I think about plugging in negative 4 in for d, I
would get negative 8 ... &gt;&gt; Plus 1, which is negative 7. &gt;&gt; So there are two
possible values of d that make this equation true.